all right we got michael saylor who
tweeted out uh yesterday i think this is
saying uh there is no inflation as long
as you don't wish to buy anything going
up in price uh which is obviously a
tongue-in-cheek way to say inflation is
absolutely out of control now the u.s
stock market took it on the chin again
tuesday who wrote that is that uh from a
cnbc article by the way can i ask you a
question about microstrategy and michael
sailor how much do you think michael
saylor will be worth one day
i think that michael saylor
has two main drivers of his personal net
worth he has uh what was about 225 250
million for the bitcoin that he bought
around um i think it was like 10 to 15
000
so uh let's say that that's up about 4x
so he probably has personally a billion
dollars worth of bitcoin now um and then
he
owns a a considerable amount of
microstrategy stock i'm sure we can
figure out uh this is a ridiculous
question do you think he could be a
trillionaire one day i think that
there's going to be a lot of
trillionaires uh in the future and uh
he's got a shot if you said to me right
now pick somebody who has a
shot to be the richest man in the world
yeah but is not on everyone's radar yeah
michael's saying i agree would be the
person who's got a shot yeah right he's
got he's got 115 roughly thousand
bitcoin right now micro strategies
michael
yeah
how much of the stock does he does do we
know but we make this joke that uh it
used to be a big deal to be a
millionaire then it became a big deal to
be a billionaire and now it's going to
be a really big deal when people start
to aspire to be trillionaires that's
right that's why the trillionaire energy
came from is we're just like
i was going to steal that sweater
you can have this one no problem because
if i do that then i can help even more
people
because it is expensive but uh right
like it looks like he owns about uh 2.4
million shares two points about 24 of
the company all right so he owns 24 of
the company which means he's got of a
5.6 billion dollar business he's got
another billion you know billion and a
half dollars or so of uh of
microstrategy stocks so right there
that's two and a half billion plus
whatever else um and so if you look at
that the richest people in the world
right now are somewhere between let's
call it a 180 220 uh billion right so he
literally has a hundred x essentially
to go to just reach where they are yeah
but
i tend to think that uh you know he's
got a shot which is like pretty crazy
like what was his name uh bernard arnott
from lbmh yeah he came out of nowhere
right i mean he was only worth 30
billion maybe 20 billion uh before the
pandemic and then the pandemic hit and
stock took off
now he he elon musk and jeff bezos have
like a daily competition as to who's
going to be the richest man in the world
yeah i mean 115 000 bitcoin if it goes
to a million 5 million that's somewhere
between 100 and 500 billion why are you
so bearish i'm just saying
those are numbers that i think people
will at least like consider what's up
guys bang bang thanks so much for
watching the best business show today if
we're gonna be the best business show we
obviously need the best partner that's
why the exclusive sponsor the best
business show is sofi they're an
all-in-one platform that allows you to
invest in all kinds of different assets
including stocks etfs crypto ipos and
they even have an automated investing
function if that's your thing so before
we start getting after it again make
sure that you go download sofi you get
an invest account and when you make your
first crypto trade regardless of what
you buy they'll give you ten dollars in
bitcoin for free it's that simple head
on over to sofi.com to get started today
thanks so much for watching and i hope
you come back and watch more the best
business show tomorrow
[Music]
you